fun fact planet earth is 4.5 billion
years old mankind about 140,000 years
old let me put that in perspective if
you condense the Earth's life span into
24 hours that's one full day then we
have been here on this planet for
drumroll please three seconds three
seconds and look what we've done
we have modestly named ourselves Homo
sapiens meaning wise man but his man
really so wise smart yes and it's good
to be smart but not too smart for your
own good yes we have split the atom yes
we build clever machines that navigate
the universe in search of new homes but
at the same time those atoms we split
created nuclear warfare in our quest to
explore the galaxy rejects and neglects
the home that we have here now so no
that cannot be wisdom wisdom is
different while intelligence speaks
wisdom listens and we willingly covered
our ears to mother nature screams and
closed our eyes to all of her help
wanted signs wisdom knows that every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction so if we were wise we would not
be shocked we see storms that are
stronger than ever before or more
droughts hurricanes and wildfire than
ever before because there's more
pollution than ever before more carbon
more trees cut down than
for at a record pace we have increased
the extinction of animals by 1,000 times
the normal rate what a feat in the next
ten to a hundred years every beloved
animal character and every children's
book is predicted to go extinct lions
gone rhinos gone
Tiger gorilla elephant polar bear gone
in three seconds species that have been
here longer than us will be gone because
of us in this three seconds and in
existence shorter than a vine video we
turn the circle of life into our own
personal conveyor belt somebody anybody
help we were given so much the only
planet in this solar system with life I
mean we are one in a million
no actually scientifically we are one in
a billion trillion trillion that's the
one that followed by 33 zeroes and I
don't want to get too spiritual but how
are we not a miracle we are perfectly
positioned to the Sun so we don't burn
but not too distant so we don't turn to
ice
Goldilocks said it best we are just like
this paradise where we are given
medicine from trees not coincidentally
but because like the song says we are
family literally everything every
species is connected genetically from
the sunflower to the Sun fish and this
is what we must recognize before it's
too late because the real crisis is not
global warming environmental destruction
or animal
culture it is us these problems are
symptoms of us byproducts of us are in a
reflection loss of connection has
created this misdirection we have
forgotten that everything contributes to
the perfection of mother nature
corporations keep us unaware and
disconnected but they have
underestimated our strength contrary to
popular belief millions are waking up
out of their sleep saying our home being
taken right up under our feet we cannot
allow a history to be written by the
wicked greedy and loony it is our duty
to protect Mother Nature from those who
refuse to see her beauty call me crazy
but I believe we should have the right
to eat food that's safe with ingredients
we can pronounce drink water that is
clean marvel at trees breathe air free
of toxins these are natural rights not
things that can be bargained for in
Congress see they want you to feel
powerless but it has been said that
something as small as the flutter of a
butterfly's wing can cause the typhoon
halfway around the world will when
enough people come together we too will
make waves and watch the world into a
new era filled with love and connection
freedom for all without oppression but
it is up to you yes you watching this
behind this screen to make the effort
because time is of the essence and only
together can we make it to the fourth
second
[Music]